No, I've met lots of people who were suicidal because of that,
but also unwilling to take care of themselves, you know,
because there was so guilty about who they were and,
and their motive being in the world that they just felt that they weren't worth
the dam. You know, and, and
while in there all have their own particular reasons for,
for believing that their own failures,
their own improper sacrifices,
let's say their own acts of individual malevolence,
but there are some DAP in a lovely metaphorical manner,
a horrifying metaphorical manner in those ancient stories.
And those stories explained to us to why as well,
that our consciousness don't sit well with us and why we always feel that
there's something undone that we should be doing in the world,
which is a much better pathway to take by the way,
then to degenerate into nihilism and, and catastrophe.
And so, and that's really ruled too. It's like, well,
you should treat yourself like you're someone responsible for helping.
And the first question is, well, why don't you? And the answer is,
well, there's a lot wrong with you, you know,
and it's hard to exercise
enough, love and care.
They're in a deep and non naive way to care properly
for something like that. But, you know,
you do it for people that you love despite their inadequacies.
And there is this idea that there is a spark of divinity within us,
and it is possible that the fact that you have that spark of
divinity with you within you also means that you have the
capability to withstand that terrible vulnerability.
That's what I was trying to get at in chapter one,
which was to stand up straight with your shoulders back,
that you could actually voluntarily accept the onslaught of the
tragedy of being and that you can constrain the proclivity for
malevolence. That's part of you and that's part of the world.
And in that you can discover your own value,
your own intrinsic value in your own nobility and,
and all of that might be more powerful than the forces of vulnerability
and malevolence themselves, which I also happen to believe.
And I think that that is in some sense, the fundamental hallmark of faith.
And so chapter two, and to some degree, chapter three,
which is to surround yourself with people who want the best for you is
a,
it's an encouragement to assume to act out
the proposition that even if life is as difficult
as it seems to be,
and if you're as vulnerable and weak in a fundamental sense,
as you definitely and characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of voluntary
suffering on yourself and others, and that destructive tendency,
that there's still something within you. That's so remarkable.
So aligned with,
with orders and being in the proper manner that you can climb above that,
let's say like a table and that you can make the proper sacrifices and that you
can set yourself, right. And you can set your family, right.
And you can set the world, right.
And that the mere possibility that that might occur,
that that might be within the realm of potential means
that you have a moral obligation to exercise the responsibility,
to take care of yourself as if you're something that matters.
And that if you did that properly,
it might turn out that what you did would matter that it would matter to
you that it would be meaningful in the way that things that matter are
meaningful and that it would matter to everyone around you.